That's another thing that freaks me out as climbing.
Did you do much climbing?
That was a lead climber up until the point where I don't have a use of my ankle
anymore because of the nerve injury.
Oh.
And it's funny is I'm actually,
I don't like heights.
You Free Solo at all.
Uh,
as long as I wasn't more like thin three feet off the ground.
Yes,
I'm totally comfortable free soloing and moving laterally,
but not vertically away from the ground.
Cause I see,
oh my God,
I watched it three times in a row.
And here's the thing,
I know he's alive.
I know he was on your podcast.
I listened to it.
And in the final scenes I realized I was sitting there white knuckling my
recliner,
like my hands were sweating.
I'm like,
I know he lives,
but it still freaked me the fuck out.
Wow.
I mean that guy.
Yeah,
he's something.
But you know what's interesting about climbing as you get,
uh,
the more exposure you have,
the less it bothers you.
Like I,
uh,
so lead climbing is interesting,
especially if you are placing your protection as you go.
If it's drilled in bull saying league or lead Lea de like someone's in front of
you,
you're a rope.
As a lead climber you are probably setting the ropes,
at least in my old job,
you're setting the ropes for the people who are going to follow them.
Okay.
Most of the time when you see people,
well if not most of the time,
but one of the disciplines would be,
there's bolted routes that go up a rock.
So you can just bring,
you know karabiners and put the Caribbean or through that and you loop the rope
through it and you're good to go.
Another aspect would be is you don't use the bolted and stuff and you basically
carry on your climbing harness,
a rack of gear.
So as you're holding onto the rocks,
you're trying to wedge a block or a stopper in or a cam system that it rotates
to be smaller than as you release it opens up and if you pull against it,
it locks itself into the rock.
So you're setting your own protection and trust those things.
So that was the point that I was getting too.
Sometimes you get to the place and you're like,
this is the perfect piece of gear.
And of course you're only like six feet off the ground when the perfect piece of
gear.
And then you'll get multi pitches up in the air.
She'd be two,
300 feet up in the air.
And you're a lead climber,
so there's nobody above you and you're setting your own pro and you're starting
to get emotionally involved in the situation that you're in.
And you set a piece of pro and it's,
it's rattling around a little bit.
So I don't know.
We don't know how good that one's going to be,
but we're going to keep climbing.
And then the next piece of pro,
you said not the most awesome piece because you're worried about the one beneath
you and you don't want to fall.
So you get it in there and then you just keep climbing.
So sometimes it's awesome and sometimes it's terrifying.
And then you've got to think that if you do fall,
all that force,
if one pops and then the second one pops you,
you've got a lot of distance.
Well you gotta think it's double the distance.
If you're a 10 feet above the last piece of protection you put in,
you fall the 10 feet to the protection,
then the 10 feet past the protection,
clink,
and then it pulls on the PR on the pro.
So it's actually double the height that you are above it.
It's not,
I've been probably more scared out of my mind actually.
The scarcity scares I've ever is that you are lived in Boulder,
right?
Yeah.
There's a client,
they're called the best steel crack.
Uh,
it's in one of the national parks and I was there with a buddy and it was just
me and him and a world class climber.
And I was at the East Coast Command at the time.
So budget was no option.
I had the newest shiny stuff.
I'm like taking plastic off of climbing gear to go climb this rock.
This guy pulls up in a van with a Marlboro hanging out and you know,
tennis shoes that have laces probably on one of them,
one of the,
one of the shoes and a,
and an old pair of pants.
And he's climbed like every mountain ever.
So it's me and my buddy were climbing our way up.
I'm leading this pitch.
So you switched,
one guy will climb,
he sets an anchor,
the other person comes up and they pick all the protection out so you can just
switch and then the other person leads the way on the next one.
So I'm like halfway up this pitch and I can't move because I'm losing my shit.
I'm like 15 feet above the last piece of protection that I just put in.
I'm convinced that I feel my feet slipping off of the rock I'm holding.
I had my hand jammed into the rock and then you make a fist to like,
you know,
prevent it from falling out.
You can actually see Alex doing that in free solo as he's climbing up those
slide their hand in and then they'll manipulate the shape.
So it pulls and as I'm,
my world is collapsing on me and I'm just sitting there,
I've got full sewing machine leg just sitting there just shaking.
I hear a voice just over my shoulder.
He's like,
hey man,
just put the piece of pro right there and I look over and this professional
climber is right next to me with no rope in his fucking tennis shoes,
smoking a cigarette,
which is what he was using to point to where I should have placed the next piece
of protection.
Cool,
calm and collected.
And I almost fell off the rock because he scared me so bad.
I was so freaked out of what he was doing that I almost fell.
I'm like,
you need to get away from me immediately.
He's like,
yeah,
no problem.
Just scurried up the rock and tennis shoes,
tennis shoes,
tennis shoes.
But you're not supposed to use tennis shoes,
right?
I don't think it mattered.
I think the guy like he was a partial complete monkey.
He just,
when you're around worldclass climbers,
I mean they can hang on an edge that is like a couple pieces of paper and this
and the steel crack is not a difficult route.
So I'm sure there was one right next to it and he just,
as I'm freaking out,
he's just sitting there just hey buddy.
And I didn't know he was there.
I literally almost fell off because he talked to me smoking a cigarette.
Yeah,
he was asking,
he was like,
put a piece of pro right here.
Get away from me.
Different kinds of heat.
But I guess it's one of those things where it's like you're better at it.
You just,
yeah.
After a week of climbing,
you will not feel bad about walking up to the edge and just standing there.
Alex Honnold was telling us a story about one time it was free soloing and he
was halfway up and he,
well he was in the middle of this journey up this fucking mountain.
He realize he didn't bring any powder,
so didn't have any chalk with them.
Whew.
So his hands are sweating and he's just climbing within the no powder.
So he met a guy halfway up these guys that were using ropes and you know,
they were doing it the right way and he's doing it with no ropes.
And he goes,
Hey man,
can I borrow your chalk?
And the guy gives him a chalk bag and he goes,
I'll leave it for you.
At the top of the mountain.
So he takes the chalk bag,
passes these guys.
See Ya.
Yeah.
It just keeps going and then leaves the bag for the guy at the top of the hill.
I'm like,
what in the fuck man.
How could you start something like that.
Like an apparently said that once you start climbing,
you are committed to climbing.
It's harder to climb down than up.
Fuck Ugh,
look,
there's not enough money in the world that would make me attempt this stuff that
he does and if I was a climber had left,
I was like,
you know,
feeling like I'm kicking ass on man.
Fill my head,
sweaty,
fill my hand just talking about it.
I sweat like a pig.
I'm telling.
I was watching it,
white knuckling and if I was a climber and he passed me and was like,
Hey,
do you mind if I borrow your Chuck Chalk?
I would finish that climb and never climb again.
Yeah.
I would realize that I am a complete and utter bitch in comparison to what he is
like if that's what's possible.
And I'm sitting here like struggling,
I'm like,
I'm out.
You're also built wrong for it,
you know,
I think the thin wirey guys,
it's the way to go.
He also has like these three elements.
Yes.
Fingers man.
His fingers are just used to occur.
Yup.
Just grabbing.
But he also said that he had gone through a series of injuries for the first
time in his life,
like recently over the last few years.
Yeah.
That was in the movie actually a like a compression of his disks and then a
really bad strain on his ankle and he was telling to take six months off since
we just started climbing in a cast.
Sure.
So it's a different kind of human,
I mean he also lives out of a van.
I mean he's world famous guy who's living in a van traveling around just fucking
climbing rocks.
Did you have him on after he had completed that climb?
Like they were,
yeah.
Okay.
So he had been successful and they were just probably editing the project.
I had them on earlier,
like years ago.
Yeah.
And then I had them on again recently.
Okay.
Yeah.
It's uh,
the guy I would want to talk to is Jimmy Chin,
the,
the photographer who is capturing all that.
Oh,
he's up there with them.
Right.
That's the thing I would want to talk well,
and he talks about it a little bit more so in the promos for the film,
but the,
how sketched out he was to actually be involved and sit there and film and how
much of a burden he felt to like stay out of the periphery and not engage,
get engaged in the headspace and make Alex do something different because the
cameras were there.
That would of course cost him his life.
I can't imagine the pressure of doing that or just,
I wouldn't do it.
Like if a buddy of mine was like,
Hey,
will you come fill me?
Uh,
you know,
free.
I would say no,
because that would be so afraid of just watching them peel off.
Oh can you imagine if you were up there filming and you watch the guy and fall,
that'd be rough.
And there are,
of course good friends and this guy,
yeah dude as maa savage,
he's got his hands on a camera only.
Well he's,
he's got a bunch of stuff.
So you see his foot,
his left foot is in,
he's kind of sick.
Yeah,
he's kind of secured down there.
He's got that carabiner.
He's got one going to his harness is actually,
you've got two ropes,
go into his harness.
So he's kind of angled and there's like a triangle,
but he's a world class climber in and of himself.
We also has a giant ass camera bag.
Look at that big ass bag hanging from his hip.
Look at that position he's in to,
oh fuck all this Jimmy.
So that's how they get in.
That's I,
they get into position for a lot of it.
He's Giumarra instead of climbing the rock,
he's got basically a senders that will lie to push it up and then they lock on
the rope.
So he's got one leg in there and one arm and he's Kinda Giumarra.
We use those a lot of the times as well,
but he is a world class climber in and of himself.
I can kind of think you'd have to be right in order to be able to capture that.
Yeah.
The team that I think they put together was like five to seven worldclass guys.
But there's a movie of him called Ma.
Yeah,
no thanks.
What does that,
what does that guy doing?
He's hanging probably 3000 foot over nothing focusing on capturing the shot.
I would be focusing on the urine streaming down.
My leg would be,
yeah.
Oh my God.
Soaking your socks.
Oh God.
Like I couldn't do that,
but I could go to the edge of that cliff and zip up my suit.
Absolutely no problem.
And send that off there and I bet you he would want a piece of that.
It's so bizarre.
Yeah.
If you shoot an Alex who's shooting him to,
good question,
is there a third prayers out around like this Mike Mikey shooting Jimmy in the
Free Solo movie?
I think they had a team of like five to seven people they had,
so they had long lens,
they had people up there,
they had remote cameras.
I mean it's a whole,
they obviously had drones flying around.
Yeah,
well there was a film that,
you know,
that besides this film,
the recent documentary,
which is a thing,
it's called Solo presale presale though before that there was also a late night
one of those new shows like ABC world news tonight or something like that.
They did a whole piece on him and they had this one guy who was a,
you know,
world class climber instead.
It's not a matter of if it's a matter of when he falls,
every innovator in the wingsuit world yeah.
Is Dead.
Yeah.
It's uh,
I mean,
but at the same,
I say that I would totally agree with that,
but I also understand why he's doing it.
I mean,
the end state for all of us is predetermined and I would suspect having never
talked to the guy that he would rather meet his end like that than at 80 years
old as a geriatric.
Yeah.
I would imagine.
Says,
but that doesn't ease the burden on the people around him.
And that's the,
that's the piece that was the toughest for me,
uh,
when it came to the wingsuit base,
jumping him there.
It's insane.
There's wrong with that,
man.
But meanwhile,
he's such a nice guy.
When you talk to Alex in real life,
he's a sweetheart.
You root for him to quit.
Like,
look,
man,
you already did it.
Stop.
I have yet to hear him express desire to do so though.
He's not quitting.
You know?
I mean,
I don't know,
man.
Everybody is built different.